The final project for
this class is building a supervised classification algorithm that can tell,
based on our Enron data set, who at Enron was a suspected person of
interest in the fraud case that happened when the company went bankrupt.
In this mini-project, you're actually going to build your first iteration of
this person of interest identifier.
So, the first thing will be building a, a sort of minimum viable product.
We're not expecting it to be really great,
we're not expecting it to be really optimized, but you'll have something up and
running in the first part of this mini-project.
In the second part of the mini-project,
we're going to wrap this in a training testing framework.
So that from this point forward, when you go in and you compute the accuracy of
your person of interest identifier, you have it all set up properly so
that it's, it's computing that accuracy on the test set like it should be.
And then from this point forward, once you have this code set up, your job is
just going to be then to fill in all the features that you want to use or
do any transforms, things like that.
So, let's get started on building that code framework.